I'm here with Russ Merlin so excited to
be talking to one of the white walkers
hi tan very nice to meet you now of
course we meet your character at the end
of season 2 on a bit of a cliffhanger
don't mean what was it like you making
that big entrance it was fantastic
I had two months of training horseback
riding without a saddle so that was
amazing for me we shot everything on
green-screen at Shepperton Studios so
despite the cold effect it was actually
boiling hot on set it was very very warm
but it was brilliant in order to get the
full effect when we were shooting it
they brought me in from makeup on the
horse they just flew up in the barn
doors and then rode me in onto the set
so the whole cast were just like oh my
god it's a white Walker yeah so it was
great it was really it was a great rush
I mean it was fantastic it was a very
easy shoot it was you know very laid
back and fun we tried loads of
variations working with a black horse a
white horse it was really cool now walk
me through what it's like getting
physically made into a white Walker
because there's a lot of stuff going on
in there in this picture you can see
behind it unless of course it's just a
top half isn't it yes well from the neck
down it's relatively straightforward it
comes in two pieces it's sort of like a
wetsuit almost but everything is molded
exactly to my body and it takes
approximately two months to make the
entire build for me getting in it's
about four hours and makeup and a
majority of that is the head and the
blending between the neck and the
shoulder areas and the hands and all of
the feet work because working bare feet
the other thing is the eyes although
that's computer-generated the two blue
eyes there I had to wear black contacts
which were quite large so wearing these
two really deep black contact lenses
were quite difficult for someone who has
never wore in contact lenses before is
this a bit like the Clockwork Orange
trying to put them in it was like
no but it was great it's a great team
very relaxed you have to have a bit of
patience obviously to be sitting there
in the chair but I really enjoy it
I couldn't meditate you know when that's
going on the work around the eye is
probably the hardest you get very very
bitty pointed sort of work but that's
really the biggest challenge with the
makeup really in that costume
I'm guessing it's it's quite hot as well
if it's something like a wet suit and
you're in a studio with lights and all
of that how do you kind of keep your
composure concentrate on what you've got
to do hit your marks and everything when
you're kind of feeling like that well
it's funny because because it's like a
wetsuit when the weather outside is hot
you get very hot when the weather
outside gets cold you get very cold
because when the soup gets cold you get
very cools and suit gets hot you get
very hot so that can be a little bit of
a challenge hitting my marks and stuff
everybody kind of makes it easy for you
they you know you walk through it a bit
the last shoot I did was to night shoots
that's what's coming up in series 3 that
was that was a little bit more
challenging because I think as you work
throughout the night your body
temperature naturally drops and because
it was working barefoot that could be a
little bit of a challenge but you know I
enjoy doing it loads I love playing
white Walker it's crazy it's nice to
have hair as well what little hair he
has I'm very happy to be working with
and it's crazy blows around a little bit
and gets in my marathon I think well
that's what it's like to have hair again
you really enjoy it and obviously
they're talking about the makeup that
you get in meditate and stuff so
obviously that keeps you kind of calm
and cool and under pressure I don't know
that you've done a lot of physical serum
mask work in fact before haven't you so
how does that help you when you are
playing something like the white Walker
I think that is probably key to how I
maybe got into this really is mask work
is very specific you when you put a mask
on unlike prosthetics the prosthetics
move with every feature you have which
is fantastic development but when you
put a mask on in
like old-style theater nothing really
moves so you really have to articulate
your head movements and accentuate your
body movements so I was really I trained
a lot as a physical actor really quite a
bit of dance training a bit of combat
training as well they all kind of lead
into each other it's always unusual not
working with your own face especially
when you see the end results like this
and you kind of go oh that's me
but then when everybody goes wow that
was so cool you think okay that's me
breathing man I look old but it's great
it's really good I mean you know it's
fantastic working with different to be
able to work with a character that is so
completely different than your own face
is a gift really and that is testament
to the prosthetics Department corner of
Sullivan and their team creatures
limited yea worked on Clash of the
Titans is with the same team and that
was very challenging that was 40 pounds
of prosthetic and very heavy it was very
very hot so we were working with real
fire or real steam on set and I was
mostly blind it was because the witch is
blind and clashing Titans so that was a
very challenging shoot but again after
the first four hours when you kind of
iron out the what we're doing and how
we're gonna lay out the day's it just
became easy work and it was a lot of fun
and the end result was hilarious for me
you know sitting there going that's me
it's really huge overweight woman I do
look a little bit like Iggy Pop I think
wrinkly and muscly it's crazy talking
about Isis of course she couldn't see it
and you mentioned about the black
contacts you said how they were I mean
could you actually see with those how
did they work yeah you can see through
the black contact completely that's not
a problem
you just get a bit of blurry vision
around the edges you need to keep
topping up with like saline solution and
stuff but they're fine once they're in
some people like to have them take take
them in and take them out take them in
and take note fruit let your irs but I'm
a bit like one Syrian leave them in
because getting them in was like torture
getting them out is a little bit of
torture too but I usually leave them in
for the whole day you know you're used
to using your body did that help you at
all when you come in to learn about
horseback riding horseback riding is a
whole different kettle of fish I think
the good thing was I had a natural 'ti
to throw myself into something I'd
always wanted to I love animals I love
the idea of just being on a horse when
they told me on the second day that I
was gonna be riding without a saddle I
was a little bit nope but I loved it I
had like I have good balance - I think
you kind of need some good balance of
you riding without a saddle I loved it
it was that was a gift I mean I'm in my
40s now but they went out of their way
to train me up to ride a horse I was
like awesome I can't wait get me on the
horse you know and I had people down the
devil's Horseman who trained me they
were just amazing
yeah the training and also how long did
it take
shooting this final scene in Episode two
well about two main series to having
yeah seriously two months to build the
suit really
I'm the makeup and everything and doing
makeup tests I would say I had about two
months training on a horse and then it
was two-day shoot for that one and a
half minute two minutes on screen shows
so much in this show is the time the
energy the care the effort that's
putting credit really comes across on
the screen knew that work that HBO and
everyone is so shows within the
production and the actors put into it
anything yeah I think that's that is the
key is they have an attention to detail
which is immaculate you know they wanted
everything to be right for the white
walkers entrance they wanted it to be
the best cliffhanger that could possibly
be in the history of television
I mean I saw there was a list of the top
ten
hangers in television history in the
States I think jr. being shot on Dallas
was number one and the white walkers
entrance was number two I thought I'll
take that that's good yeah on horseback
you make a really kind of guttural noise
kind of to egg the people on today call
the white walkers and the whites on so
kind of go into battle tell me about
where did that come from the sound
Department yeah I could do the best I
could with my own voice but sound
department did everything else was
awesome it was it was actually very much
how I imagined it was described to me at
the audition and by DB Weiss and David
being off they were like it's gonna be
this like ice kind of frosty breaking
glass sort of screeching so everything
in my head was like okay and then when I
heard it I was like yeah that's it but
it's really cool now of course season
three is already started it's tremendous
as we would have expected you're
enjoying it yourself I know what are you
looking forward to from your character
and from the other characters in the
show well what am I looking forward to I
can't lie Mon I've seen episode 1 and
episode 2 I cannot wait to see more of
the Dragons so the outside of my
character that's what I really love I
love the Dragons and then I guess when I
was a little boy that's what I loved the
most was dragons and all of that and
watching the Dragons kind of develop and
Calista's story is incredible for my
character what am I looking forward to I
can't wait to see what the audience's
reaction is gonna be when I come back
yes I'm so excited
it'll be very dark like guaranteed
it's this kind of show we're talking
about before that really keeps you on
your toes I posed as an audience I guess
an actor as well
in terms of you know anything could
happen always literally oh yeah anything
could happen at any time to anybody you
know characters sometimes are there one
moment and they're going the next you
know so it's one of those shows that
really keep their audience on their toes
isn't it you kind of never know what's
gonna happen characters never know where
they're gonna go what do you think you
need to survive or thrive even in the
world of Game of Thrones cuz we've seen
so many fall by the wayside mm-hmm what
you need to survive I think which
sometimes I think I think I look at John
Bradley's character Sam and I think
because he's he's a survivor you know
he's a really long-term survivors
character it's a very well-rounded
character you know you always want to
know more of where this character is
gonna go so I think if you have an area
that you can develop like where is this
character gonna be and maybe five six
seven episodes that's a great thing I
think sometimes characters it's good to
pull them out when you don't know what's
gonna happen to them but it's you know
it's a real guessing game on Game of
Thrones you just have no idea where
they're gonna turn next if you could be
anybody else who'd like to be Wow what a
question well I think my favorite
character well I've got to I do like I
love Sam I love trying to get to work
with him so I'm very partial to him but
I love Kelis as well I love the you know
the mother of all dragons and I love
that I love her kind of area of the
story I guess because it's really hot
and I'm always in the cold so one of
those characters would be really great
part of her tribe got to kind of put
just up to where little clothing that
would be great going to a hot set like
somewhere nice and sunny so my day off I
could layer the Sun and swim yeah
absolutely
now if you could have to be anyone else
yourself you would you be though in Game
of Thrones who would I be I guess
well I'd be sitting on the throne of
course I'm very good you look on it -
yeah Robb Stark I guess yeah yeah he's
good character I mean that's that's the
place I want to be yeah nice choice I
like it what's it that you mentioned
John Barclay they're working with those
guys on sir he's such it I haven't eaten
before he's such a lovely guy yeah he's
extremely lovely he was brilliant work
with on series two he came in and all he
did was hiding behind a rock with me but
always there is my line always you know
really lovely guy I had more to do with
him in Series three which was great
we had a two-day shoot together with him
and Hannah and yeah I loved working
these really lovely guys good we're just
sitting around on set and having a chat
it's just nice I think it was jolts and
he plays pips that he's a really funny
guy as well that he keeps everyone
laughing on set yeah yeah Josef Alton
just over there yes yes I follow him on
Twitter he's hilarious I only actually
met him for the first time this morning
at breakfast yeah and now we're just
kind of shooting swords that one another
across the room they didn't get on man
losers they really get on with anybody
though no I wouldn't have thought so
well maybe with each other I don't know
yeah we'll see you've got to have some
friends in this world what is it meant
to to be part of Game of Thrones because
I say it's such a popular show everyone
loves it so much it's fantastic when I
first got the call for the audition I
actually hadn't watched the show at all
so I kept calling a king of Thrones so I
had to do a bit of my homework and then
of course the day before my audition I
watched the first episode and I was like
oh wow this is really cool
and then I watch the whole series I was
blown away I kind of wasn't sure I had
to kind of start looking into where this
story had come from and found out that
there were books it seemed that some of
the characters almost seemed steeped in
real history like the King seemed almost
like King Henry the eighth and you know
it's fantastic I mean it's it's always
wonderful to be part of something that
is very creative well thought out well
written I've been very fortunate in my
career that I have worked with a lot of
Game of Thrones is no different we've
been very very fortunate what would you
like to say to fans of Game of Thrones
so watching this video this interview
with you
winter is coming
you